i remember is there any uni student who
lives a healthy life there was there was
one guy in my
my like uh year and he was like the the
peak form of
everything he like wouldn't drink he
went gym like every single day and
he always was the best but like smells
like had fun what clubs was he part of
because i remember people who were like
part of the rowing club or
some kind of sports club would have
always the peak optimal lifestyle
and then there was like everyone else
who just like
yeah but that would usually be the one
to where they would be walking down you
know the campus and people would know
that they're part of their club and i
would just be like look at this wanker
because they they wear like they're like
i'm in this club yeah yeah yeah yeah
look at wanker wearing a polo shirt he
can afford a polo shirt
get out of here [ __ ] off i
i feel like because i went straight into
youtube from uni
yeah like you got the uni lifestyle i
kind of just didn't change
anything except for like like i even
like i even like had an approach to
youtube making
in uni like i was like procrastinating
my videos the way i was
doing with my lectures right right where
i would like not do anything and then
one day i would just do everything and
then i'd be like wow what a healthy
i was the opposite because i started
youtube when i started uni yeah
right so i kind of live like a double
life but usually
it's supposed to be the opposite where
it's like you should focus on
your studies right and like keep you
know maintained
and you know live the model life as a
movie student and then youtube just
because it's a hobby right you can just
procrastinate and just do whatever now
for me was the complete opposite i was
like all right
upload videos every day at this time get
it edited
get it done oh [ __ ] i have an assignment
in two days i think
everyone who is who's like seeing good
growth
does that though because i knew that i
should have put engineering first but i
i didn't
no i put the youtube first yeah i don't
know how you managed to do daily uploads
while also going to university and still
passed i mean
it's some of the easiest content that
i've ever made and like also
like compared to videos now i wouldn't
call my old videos
good editing because there was barely
any editing it was like
lots of cuts lots of zoom ins it's like
the easiest [ __ ] editing
put some background music in but we got
a video right but yeah my
computer because i really struggle with
that because
obviously the upload speed in australia
is [ __ ] horrendous
like to dude yeah the internet like the
download was fine
we had like 20 down right we're just
like not bad
not bad right but you know what our
upload speed was like 0.1
pretty close like 0.3 oh my god oh god
so
uploading a like 500 meg video file
yeah which is like nothing right yeah
would take me like
eight hours jesus so what i would have
to do
is i would go to my classes i'd come
back
i would work on a video i'd edit it
until the night and then i would upload
it
and then go to sleep and by the time i
got up in the morning usually it was
like
almost finished or it was done and it
would just be public by that point and i
would do that
every day for three years and
unsurprisingly
it was like i think it was like a month
before i decided to move to japan right
my computer just exploded like
physically like i was sitting there i
was editing i remember i was editing a
nekopara episode right that i was doing
and then one day just went boom it's
nekopara
that's nekopara like it's just it just
explodes like the cpu just exploded
and there's smoke coming up and
everything i'm like oh my this house is
gonna go down like
this house is gonna catch on
yeah this is this is how like house fire
starts and yeah so we got rid of it and
i opened up i remember i opened up the
computer and my cpu was just
gone it was just disintegrated it must
have been constantly on you must have
never
yeah and the computer's just like not
can't do it anymore man
wait did did you live at home when
you're at university yeah oh [ __ ] that's
been such a different experience
yeah yeah because i i never got the
experience of like living in like a dorm
right because i like
having roommates i moved out at 18 and i
just turned 18
and i've pretty much lived alone or like
not with my parents since then
yeah i moved out after union sounds like
a fun idea until it's really not after
about two months of living with other
people
yeah you realize man i really hate
people they're like well because you
don't get a say in who you're put with
in at least british university oh really
and uh yeah sometimes you get put with
people you're like i hate this
i was put with like the rugby team
basically right and they were like
destroying everything constantly and
yeah i remember one time
i had like a pan specifically for
putting oven pizzas on right right
and he was like can i borrow it and i
was like well you know he's like
seven foot ten built like a brick [ __ ]
house
sure it was like it was like a one pound
tray from little
right i was like yeah sure anyway i go
in the kitchen at night to go and get
like a beverage
and i see my pizza tray and there's just
a carcass of a whole
chicken a whole chicken was cooked on my
pizza tray
and he just left it and i was like
there's no way i can get this [ __ ] off
it's like
charred on yeah it's not even worth
saving the tray i'm like
you didn't borrow it you just liberated
it
you just took it from me and destroyed
it i just couldn't believe it i was like
my mom's gonna be furious at that one
pound tradition
furious how do i explain this to mother